shane mcclanahan making his return and
his 23rd start of the season the era
3.59 in 110 and the third innings of
work his last start came back on the 8th
of
september a cut and a miss torrey is out
on stripes to begin this game waits on
another 3-2 offering and he draws his
90th walk of the year
and a swing and dives comes back to
strikeout cabrera fastball slider and
splitter those are his pitches he uses
the splitter as a combination change up
and breaking pitch
high chop
right side goodgram has to wait and no
play
[Applause]
the one that's a broken back brown to
the third could be two
the relay from harold castro's in time
eric costrows a four-pitch free pass
with one out here in the second
goodrun takes
loader for strike three called
that is strike three
call and ball four and again
a miss not by much
a little tight and it got him just broke
him
so rosarena is hit by a pitch
three for ten in the series here's the
1-1
ground ball to short could be two again
turn in time
two innings two double plays
castro the other way
off the glove of the third baseman diaz
no play for wendell
a bunt laid down by reyes that'll move
the runner
swing and a miss big strikeout
in the inning on the breaking ball
there's that splitter just filthy
first strikeout of the day for willie
peralta
he lines it into center that's going to
be in there a big hop cut off by reyes
janino with a turn but he'll hold
there goes the runner the throw from
garneau
in time to get brandon lau who went head
first it looked like brandon got there
in time i think the only thing was did
his left hand come off
no tag the hands on there oh yeah that's
that's not even close he's in there easy
he's absolutely in there
yeah he's safe 100 rbis on the year for
meadows
round ball to second on the backhand
harold castro that's a nice play and a
good way for the tigers to end the third
swing and a mess
takes care of candelario tigers only had
three base runners a couple of walks and
a single
one single since the second inning
yesterday that's it
haas puts a charge into one deep center
field you bet he did a solo bomb here to
get the tigers on the board number 22 on
the season for eric haas
[Applause]
the payoff swung on and missed willie
peralta's second strikeout of the day
and he has just walked joy
for the second time
there he goes again
swung on and missed the throw from
garneau a good one
yes he got him we have one of the game
raised two hits tigers with two hits to
chop down to third
yandy diaz whistles that one across the
diamond
the four pitch walk diaz will head to
first
[Music]
he got him looking
zunino off the handle right side get up
harold castro can't make the bare-handed
play
diaz all the way to third the throw and
trying to get him
diaz is shaking his head like no way
but the call was made at third base that
harold castro gunned him down and so
that is overturned
second time tampa's had two men aboard
off the end of the bat candelario
got him just in time
giving way to pete fairbanks in the race
bullpen as he's on for the 43rd time
that is strike three call very bottom of
the zone with that slider
here it is
back up the middle
one more closer now just 21 hits shy of
3 000 for miguel cabrera
candelario turns on one into the right
field corner it'll bounce up against the
wall a rose arena plays it on a couple
of hops cabrera cruises into third jamer
candelario has his 41st double of the
season
and strike three call
[Applause]
another wave and miss
and cruz is
out number two here
in the sixth inning that got him
catcher's interference
so the strikeout will be
overruled on catcher's interference
rosarina in the air to center field
reyes is there he's found it and he puts
it away
justin garneau i gotta imagine he's just
trying to slow the game down a little
when he's at the plate
he's done a really good job
there's a blast a deep left field
garneau goes yard again
give him a half dozen on the season the
tigers extend their lead to two
[Applause]
he's getting the bow and arrow out chip
boy he jumped all over that mistake
pitch
he was ready for it this half inning in
the seventh it's strike strike strike
for him
the o2
on the 100th pitch
eric haas is under it
and the rays go one two three into seven
there's the two two
in the air to shallow right a rosarina
watches it drop in front of him
a lead off single for jonathan scope
here in the eighth
straight three call
on the outside corner derek holland in a
wall side windows pitching change is in
he has not allowed a run in the month of
september
and there's a base head up the middle he
is three for three with three singles
[Applause]
in the air
foul territory scope
feeling his way and making the grab
there's a great indication of what can
happen when you look away from the ball
that's hitting the ceiling big
opportunity here for jason foley
and that is ball four
[Music]
kier meyer who would just put back on
the active list
will run so the rays
have some speed in caremeyer at first
the 2-1 from foley there goes the runner
the throw down in time
dustin garneau does it again
a bullet to second base to clip kevin
keermeyer and end the inning
leads off to ninth
hits it on the ground right side diving
stopped by choi and he's going to make
the play unassisted he was the only man
over there
and made that dive to come up with the
ball and record the out
now ready for the 3-2 here it is and he
draws a one-hour walk
ground ball back to the mound
now connolly is running right at him
and finally gets the tag boy that got a
little dicey there kyle funkhouser goes
to work he's looking for his first
career save
there's a base hit
the other way
to the right of gudrum
and the reigns aren't finished yet
now the 1-1
fly ball right field deep that goes
grossman he's got it and the tigers win
the season series from the rays
[Applause]